Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you want to challenge someone's ideas?
Listen out for useful language for challenging someone's ideas.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Guys! I've got it!
I've figured it out!
Figured what out?
That it's polite to knock on the door before coming in?
This idea is just too good, Paul!
It's too good!
Go on, then.
So!
Cats!
I'm a bit lost. What are you talking about?
Videos.
Cat videos!
For our social media account.
Hundreds of them.
Everyone loves cats!
I hate cats.
Everyone except you, Paul.
Have you considered the fact that we're a branding agency, not a pet shop?
I take your point, Paul,
but, come on, be imaginative!
Cat videos are some of the most searched videos on the internet.
I see where you're coming from, Vanya, but I think I agree with Paul here.
How is this relevant for a branding agency?
Look.
Social media, it's a numbers game.
If we share dozens of cat videos each day,
then we get more followers.
That's true.
So how exactly do you see this working?
I mean, who's going to find all these videos?
Erm, OK, I'm very aware of the challenges here,
but I'm convinced this is going to work.
I'm not so sure.
Well, I guess you have to look at it from both sides.
Why don't we try it for a couple of weeks and see if there's any impact?
Great!
We are going to get so many more followers.
I'm absolutely positive!
Good luck with that!
I hope it doesn't turn out to be a cat-astrophe.
What?
It's a good joke.
Hello again!
Well, I thought that was a good joke!
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for challenging someone's ideas?
Listen to me and then repeat.
I'm a bit lost. What are you talking about?
Have you considered the fact that we're a branding agency, not a pet shop?
I take your point, but be imaginative.
I see where you're coming from.
I think I agree with Paul here.
How exactly do you see this working?
I'm very aware of the challenges here, but I'm convinced this will work.
You have to look at it from both sides.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you want to challenge someone’s ideas in English.
Bye for now!